trois attaques peut-être cette nous
dit-on de source policière en tout cas
au moins trois ont été perpétrés à paris
et autour de paris
on n'a jamais connu un attentat comme ça
dans les rues de paris on n'a jamais été
confronté à une action ans de guerre
[Musique]
c'est la guerre avec l'odeur de la
poudre du sang la vision c'est la guerre
on pense pas trop hein soit on l'a on
essaie surtout de prendre les bonnes
décisions
déterminées qui a fait quoi
très bon
avec qui et pourquoi
c'est une toile le coin s'est passé
tellement énorme je pars de trois
personnes qui nous ont tiré dessus un an
après on me parle d'une quantité de gens
on me parle du financement des armes de
tout devient énorme
45000 code 45 mille pièces de procédure
mille sept cent quarante parties civiles
et 350 avocat ce jour au moins six mois
d'audiences dans une salle de 600 places
spécialement construite au coeur du
palais de justice de paris
c'est un procès de très grande ampleur
et qui donc n'est comparable à rien ce
procès en appel choix il doit être
historique
que n'at-on pas fait que n'at-on pas
empêché comment ces attentats ont ils pu
se produire
c'est la liberté qui aura le dernier mot
vous avez agi de manière effroyable vous
allez être condamné de manière
démocratique
[Musique]
l'un stade de france le coup d'envoi
dans un instant
la finale aura lieu le 10 juillet 2016
du championnat d'europe des nations
alors que vous découvrez des capitaines
[Musique]
tout devrait bien se passer ce soir face
à l'équipe de france c'est parti avec un
tournoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la première détonation fait surgir
immédiatement dès que nous pouvons avoir
dans le stade
bombes qui explosent pendant quelques
minutes nous nous pensons que ça reste
ou un pétard ou bombes agricoles
l'extérieur du stade c'est au moment la
deuxième détonation que vous les plus de
doute je prends conscience que nous
sommes peut-être devant une opération
beaucoup plus importante et qui n'est
pas terminée
[Applaudissements]
je m'éclipse à la 60e minute du match et
avec dollars 15 9 nous regagnons très
rapidement paris
[Musique]
très vite nous apprenons que il ya des
coups de feu dans les rues de paris et
qu'à ce moment là nous sommes face à une
attaque de masse j'ai été emporté par
les froids quand j'ai su tout ce qui se
produisait sans que puisse se le voir
sur les terrasses et et au bataclan ce
que les terroristes veulent c'est nous
faire peur ou saisir d'effroi il y a
effectivement de quoi avoir peur il y à
l'effroi je me rends ensuite sur place
au bataclan je vois des gens sortir du
bataclan sont encore là blessé ou pas
blessé mais comme des fantômes qui
sortent de ce lieu terrible
le 13 novembre et la soirée de ma vie
qui ressemble plus à la mort si la mort
est partout
et c'est très étrange comme sentiment
fort et où la mort ou cern
on est dans des étiages qui sont encore
jeudi une violence inouïe 130 morts
ça sent blessé c'est facile c'est
indescriptible
c'est une terrible épreuve qui une
nouvelle fois
nous assaillent nous savons d'où elle
vient qui sont ces criminels qui sont
ces terroristes nous vivons cet
événement avec le sentiment que survient
ce soir là ce que nous avions depuis
longtemps la question n'était pas de
savoir si la france est exposée à un
risque majeur on savait bien qu'on avait
un risque d'une opération
importante qui risquaient de venir
l'extérieur la question c'était plutôt
de savoir où quand et comment
[Musique]
le 13 novembre fait partie de ma vie
mais le 13 novembre ne me définis pas ça
ne définit pas qui je suis mais ça je ne
peux pas renier que ça fait partie de ma
vie est ce qu'il ya eu des choses que
j'ai fait que je n'aurais pas fait sans
le 13 novembre certainement j'ai un
fonctionnement un peu analytique j'aime
bien savoir qui fait quoi pourquoi moi
ça m'intéresse de savoir qui a voulu me
tuer quoi
ça m'intéresse de savoir pourquoi
et ça m'intéresse de savoir comment
[Musique]
l'idée de mes notes c'est essayer de
comprendre les donneurs d'ordres
l'origine
comprendre ce qui était la structure au
sein de l'état islamique il ya commandes
car comme on dit et on peut le dire les
attentes à comprendre qu'ils étaient les
différents commandos comment ils étaient
constitués
assez rapidement je me rends compte que
je vais avoir besoin de prendre un
avocat parce que je me dis
sans doute y avoir un procès même si je
suis pas sûr qu'on attrape quelqu'un
j'ai besoin de savoir ce qui se passe
en 2015 et voir tellement d'attentes a
tellement besoin est finalement assez
peu d'avocats qui sont en mesure de
répondre à la fois à flot de victimes
aux problèmes d'indemnisation aux
problèmes de pénale en france mais
ailleurs je me retrouve
l'avocat de victimes d'attentats
c'est petit à petit en travaillant les
dossiers et ambition de faire des liens
d'un dossier un autre que je vais finir
par comprendre que si ça arrive en
france à ce moment là ça n'est pas
finalement par hasard et c'est le
résultat d'un plan ourdi et concertée
we are one common moudjahidine ayman abu
talhah al
wahda l'avons bada céline abbaoui la
terminale jenna dewan
au moins de juin 2014 le calife al
bagdadi va proclamer donc le califat et
ce qui n'était qu'une organisation
terroriste devient un proto état à
cheval sur deux pays que sont la syrie
et l'irak
sont lancés dans une véritable guerre
pour occuper des territoires c'est la
première fois qu'une organisation
terroriste non seulement comme et des
attentes a
agi contre un état en l'occurrence
l'irak mais occupe un territoire occupe
une ville
[Musique]
dans le courant de l'été 2014 une
coalition internationale va se mettre à
bombarder les territoires tenus par
l'état islamique
savent a occasionné beaucoup de dégâts
[Musique]
cette organisation se doit donc de
réagir en septembre le porte parole de
l'état islamique abu mohammed al anani
déclare entre autres si vous pouvez tuer
un incroyant américains ou européens en
particulier les méchants et sale
français alors compter sur un là et tu
es le de n'importe quelle manière frappé
sa tête avec une pierre égorgé le avec
un couteau écrasez le avec sa voiture
jetée le d'un lieu en hauteur étrangler
le ou empoisonné le
se sont pas des paroles verbales ces
individus commettent des crimes et des
attaques extrêmement meurtrières en irak
et en syrie savons donc que cette menace
existe est ce qu'elle peut prendre la
forme d'attentats sur notre territoire
nous ne pouvons pas en être certains ne
savons pas encore quels sont les réseaux
qui peuvent exister en france en
belgique ou dans d'autres pays européens
[Musique]
au début on n'a pas su trop appréhender
ce qui se passait réellement en syrie
des commandos projeter on les redoute
mais on n'y croit pas il faut être très
très clair certes l etat islamique est
déjà très implanté
en syrie et en irak mais on n'imaginait
pas véritablement qu'il ait une capacité
de pouvoir projeter comme la fel qaïda
le 11 septembre chez les américains
intel commando c'est à partir de
verviers qui se situe juste un petit peu
après les attentats de 2,2 charlie hebdo
que là on s'aperçoit que il y a quelque
chose de différent c'est le premier
exemple concret de personnes qui
viennent de syrie et qui ont envie de
commettre quelque chose sur le
territoire national
c'est un pays confronté comme la france
à la menace terroriste la belgique
plusieurs opérations antiterroristes ont
été menées notamment un verviers près de
liège et à bruxelles elles visent des
groupes jihadistes de retour de syrie
qui préparerait selon les enquêteurs
plusieurs attentats
avec la séquence de verviers on est
confronté à un changement de modus
operandi qui prend de vitesse à plus ou
moins tous les services européens
d'ailleurs à ces gens qui partent là bas
ils peuvent revenir et peuvent très
dangereux et donc je pense que ce moment
là et le moment un peu charnière
[Musique]
j'étais inspecteur principal pendant 15
ans au groupe d'intervention de la dsu
l'a déçu c'est l'unité spéciale de la
police fédérale en belgique c'est
équivalent du ggn en france
[Musique]
il ya deux endroits on va dire cruciaux
où il ya un nid de terroristes présumés
c'est à dire ca à bruxelles et à février
[Musique]
un certain moment des enquêteurs
arrivent à loger les terroristes les
protagonistes à verviers
il ya des moyens techniques qui sont mis
en oeuvre ça tourne 24 heures sur 24
pour essayer un peu de voir ce qu'ils
font et dans quelle direction il
c'est des gens qui ne sortent pas
beaucoup ils sortent jamais à deux ils
sont très structurés très bien organisés
en ces mois de janvier il fait sombre y
pleut souvent il fait froid donc ils ont
ils mettre une casquette un bonnet on
les voit pas trop les identités à ce
moment là on n'est pas sûr à 100%
dans les écoutes on se rend compte qu'en
fait les gars prêts pas vraiment quelque
chose donc ça incite le parquet et la
direction de nous voir passer une
vitesse supérieure donc le jeudi à toute
une mise en place il ya deux les snipers
de chez nous qui se met en place mais il
ya aussi les collègues du gign qui s'y
met aussi
un certain moment on ne peut plus
attendre il ya un troisième qui arrive
dans la planque qu'on ne sait pas trop
ce qu'il apporte et on ne peut pas se
courir le risque de laisser sortir ces
gens là et donc on doit intervenir vers
16h car ces heures 30 on à legault le
feu vert et la soe est donné
[Musique]
dans la seconde on se on se ramasse une
rafale de kalachnikov et là on sent
directement qu'on est tombé quand même
sur des traits durs it here it here it
here bien sûr nous on riposte assez
rapidement aussi dans les 30 premières
secondes le premier éliminé par contre
il reste le deuxième qui est entre la
partie avant de l'appartement et la
partie arrière et lui
voilà c'est un dur à cuire il veut pas
se laisser faire et il veut mourir là
c'est sûr et certain
le sniper du gign propulse une grenade
qui met le feu à l'appartement
mais le gars on le voit on sait pas très
bien le situer en plus il ya une une
évacuation de fumée qui se fait à
l'avant et à l'arrière du bâtiment
lui-même avance dans cette dans cette
boule de feu il avancé là un certain
moment il y à quelques mètres d'eux de
notre équipe de mon équipe il a sept ou
huit mètres de mon équipe et là on
arrive à finir on va dire la mission
et quand tout se calme un peu après une
minute une minute et demie tout à coup
il ya un dégâts à l'arrière un des
snipers à l'arrière qui voit une ombre
dans ce dégagement de fumée et là c'est
le troisième
qui venait d'où celle qui sera en fête
l'enquète dire à part après que dans les
24 heures il voulait aller aussi faire
un carnage en uniforme de police qui ont
été aussi retrouvé dans l'appartement et
se faire péter probablement avec une
ceinture d'explosifs
donc nous savons depuis verviers que
nous nous sommes devant cette menace non
pas nouvelle parce que la menace n'a
jamais cessé mais d'opérations de
beaucoup plus grande envergure la preuve
c'est que nous verrons que les individus
qui étaient à verviers où autour de
verviers en belgique on les retrouvera
dans ce qui s'est produit
stade de france terrassé bataclan c'est
le 1er octobre par about
le nom de daoud apparaît à ce moment là
[Musique]
abdelhamid abou aoun c'est un jeune
belge qui a fait un petit peu de prison
pour de menus larcins qui certes vient
du quartier de molenbeek qui a tant
défrayé la chronique mais qui était fils
de commerçants donc issus de la classe
moyenne une classe supérieure quand il
rejoint la syrie il va montrer un
appétit pour les combats et pour les
exactions diverses et variées qui doit
commettre mais par ailleurs il va se
servir de l'argent paternelle pour
financer des achats d'armes ce qui va le
faire aussi monter en grade
about et dans les fichiers parce que on
sait qu'il est parti en syrie on sait
qu'il est revenu qu'il a enlevé son
petit frère
donc et qui l'a amené lui-même en syrie
[Musique]
je vous renvoie la vidéo dans laquelle
il se met en scène au volant d'un
pick-up en train de traîner des cadavres
dans la campagne syrienne
ross healy à cette vidéo qu'on va voir
partout où ils tractent les décors de
syriens qui viennent de tuer avec ses
avec ses complices
d'un volontarisme si j'ose dire dans
l'horreur va le faire monter en grade au
sein de l'état islamique sa promotion
provient de juillet 2014 il est nommé et
mir au sein d'une katiba qu'est la
katiba el battar il prend en ce moment
là plus de 150 combattants sous ses
ordres
[Musique]
m
about on le connaissait déjà dans le
cadre de ce dossier qui nous amène à
veyrier on apprend qu'il pourrait être à
un poste où il tire un peu les ficelles
et où il organise les choses et donc
cette information nous l'avons partager
avec l'ensemble de la communauté
policière européenne dans l' enquête on
nous dit effectivement que les gars sont
dirigés par quelqu'un qui est localisée
et en syrie ou en grèce à athènes plus
précisément
[Musique]
les services finissent par comprendre
qu'il est athènes la police grecque va
essayer d'arrêter about il a été aidé de
la dgse mais aussi des services
américains est vrai seulement du mossad
donc on a déjà là des moyens
considérables qui montre que les
services ont pris la mesure du danger
qui couvait mais malheureusement ça va
échouer
le 15 janvier quelques minutes après le
coup d'assaut contre contre verviers
services grecs ils font une sorte de
coup de filet dans un quartier où le
téléphone est géolocalisé sauf que le
coup de filet est très important dans un
quartier très fréquenté il ya énormément
de monde
about lâche son téléphone l'abandonnent
il est retrouvé quelques jours plus tard
et passent entre les mailles du filet
il rate about apparemment de ça se joue
à quelques minutes à quelques dizaines
de minutes mais il leur at il dit il
disparaît dans la nature
[Musique]
quelques semaines après paraît dans le
magazine d'habiter un magazine de
propagande de l'état islamique un
interview daoud qui se moque des forces
de l'ordre européenne en disant merde et
je fais ce que je veux je me déplace
comme je veux en europe c'est une
passoire il va se vanter d'avoir réussi
à se procurer des armes et à planifier
des opérations contre les croisés les
services vont découvrir dans un des
appartements catherine de ses planques à
athènes un ordinateur et dans cet
ordinateur les expertises vont permettre
de découvrir un projet d'attentât qui
vise l'aéroport de zaventem en belgique
[Musique]
dd janvier 2015 avec ce coup de filet de
verviers à bas ou d'apparaître comme
quelqu'un de prioritaire pour la dgse
cet individu about est repéré mais ce
serait d'ailleurs une faute de penser
qu'il est le seul puisque c'est une
chaîne en réalité et il y a
l'hiérarchie plus ou moins explicite
mais il y a des chefs des sous chefs et
des relais qui se font cet attentat
déjoué de verviers montre déjà un
premier degré de sophistication
on a à jaca les cerveaux à athènes le
coordinateur opérationnel about et en
belgique une cellule de logistique et
des tueurs
c'est malheureusement les prémices de ce
qu'ils vont être capables de faire et de
ce qu'ils vont réaliser le 13 novembre
pour revenir à l'origine de d'où
viennent les terroristes comment ils
sont rencontrés comment ils ont été
formés il faut revenir la façon dont
l'état islamique s'est structuré
[Musique]
ce ne sont pas que des jambons sandales
dans désert c'est une erreur de penser
ça sont des gens qui ont des compétences
de renseignement et des compétences dans
l'innovation militaire
l'état islamique va développer une
police secrète donc qui s'appelle la mia
tu anh en arabe ça désigne le mot
sécurité ou secrets aussi et donc c'est
le service secret fondée par l'état
islamique
pour tenir son territoire quand à partir
du moment où il a eu un territoire à
défendre
l'amiable est chaperonné par le porte
parole de l'état islamique elle a un
responsable qui à bouloc man
et ils vont avoir ce qui nous va nous
intéresser une cellule spécifique qui va
être chargé des opérations clandestines
des ce qu'on appelle les opex les
opérations extérieures en dehors des
états contrôlés par l'état islamique
[Musique]
il y à un franco algérien qui va être
très important pour notre histoire qui
s'appelle abdel nasser ben youssef donc
un ancien des camps d'al-qaïda qui a été
en géorgie qu'il voulait combattre en
tchétchénie qui lui est vraiment celui
qui a eu l'idée et qui a dit mais
attendez on va créer une cellule des
opérations extérieures ben youssef il a
vécu en france il a des origines du côté
de villepinte des mureaux il a un réseau
et c'est lui qui est le patron des
attentes c'est vraiment un vieux routier
aux côtés de benyoucef on trouve son ami
samir noyade qui est lui aussi algérien
est lui aussi un ancien du gia
et ensuite il y a les deux lieutenants
et ami très proche de benyoucef le
franco-tunisien boubakeur el hakim qui
avait été le premier français à
rejoindre al-qaïda en irak et le dernier
oussama atar donc un belge qui lui aussi
avait rejoint les rangs d'al qaïda en
irak dans les années 2000 qui aura été
en prison avec alan nani et même avec le
futur calif
pour résumer il y a deux algériens
abdelnasser benyoucef samir noyade un
franco-tunisien
boubakeur al hakim et un belge oussama
atar
ce sont ces quatre hommes qui ont piloté
tous les attentats ayant frappé l'europe
en 2015 et 2016
on va avoir des gens qui sont très
organisés qui ne se déplace que cagoulés
et qui sont des soldats extrêmement
entraîner d'une sauvagerie et c'est
souvent d'ailleurs comme ça qu'il son
côté d'une sauvagerie sans limite et
parmi ces personnages vous avez
abdelhamid about
là-bas ou death est la cheville ouvrière
on va dire c'est l'officier et des
autres sont les officiers supérieurs
c'est lui qui va recruter à la fois des
belges et des français pour les renvoyer
ensuite en les accompagnant s'il le faut
sur le sol français et belges
donc après verviers en janvier 2015
lamia tu et sa branche opep va tenter
plusieurs opérations seul principalement
coordonné par abba hood où il va
projeter des jeunes recrues qui ne sont
pas des vétérans du tout du djihad très
motivé à commettre des attentats sur le
sol français
donc la deuxième après verviers c'est la
tentative juifs commis par sid ahmed
glam au mois d'avril 2015 ou cours
duquel horny chacun trouvera la mort
sid ahmed glam jeune homme qui vit en
france il rêve de mourir en martyr
depuis un certain temps il va se rendre
en syrie il va rencontrer à ce moment là
abdel nasser ben youssef samir awad et
adela me down et on l'envoie commettre
un attentat en région parisienne
ben youssef lui indique lui propose la
gare de villepinte pourquoi villepinte
parce que
ben youssef vient d'une pinte il connaît
la gare de vie
glam très très discipliné c'est un
étudiant il est opiniâtre il bat shot
tout le temps il écrit tout ce qu'on lui
dit il va faire le tour des cibles donc
il va aller à villepinte et il va
regarder lagarde va prendre un film il
va mesurer le temps puis à dire mais
c'est un peu embêtant parce que là il ya
des caméras sur le parking donc je
risque d'être pris et 2 il ya quand même
beaucoup beaucoup d'arabes et c'est
quand même embêtant que nos victimes
soient musulmanes et donc vous le dire
mais cherche d'autres cibles et c'est
lui qui va proposer comme cible une
église
il s'appelle sid ahmed glam est âgé de
24 ans est projeté de commettre un
attentat contre ces deux églises
catholiques de villejuif en banlieue
parisienne lorsqu'il a été interpellé
l'attaqué tête imminente selon le
ministre de l'intérieur il a été plutôt
bon sur la phase de repérage les seuls
éléments qu'on a de lui c'est quand il
quittait sa résidence universitaire il y
avait une caméra dans le hall on bat le
voit partir en revanche ils aient été
assez mauvais et c'est une constante
qu'on retrouve sur beaucoup d'attentats
dans la réalisation c'est à dire qu' il
va assassiner la malheureuse
automobilistes aurélie chasselin en
revanche semble-t-il en remettant son
arme dans son jean
il n'a pas mis la sécurité et va se
tirer une balle et c'est ce qui va
mettre fin à ce qui devait être le
véritable attentat qu'il devait
perpétrés c'est à dire une tuerie dans
une église
dimanche matin à paris dans le xiiie
arrondissement la police a découvert
dans le véhicule et au domicile d'un
individu blessé par balle un arsenal
composé notamment de plusieurs armes de
guerre d'armes de poing de munitions le
gilet pare balles et de matériels
informatiques et de téléphonie ce qui
est intéressant aussi dans la sphère de
l'attentât de villejuif c'est ce que les
policiers vont trouver dans la ville
dans le véhicule dodge ram c'est un
classeur verts
dans ce classeur verts y avait des
dizaines et dizaines de pages
manuscrites sur ce qu'il fallait faire
et ne pas faire avant l'attentât pendant
l'attentât et après l'attentât
[Musique]
il
thür villejuif de nous nous nous voyons
bien que s'il a pu rater son opération
ce qu'il avait en tête c'était d'aller
dans l'église et sans doute de faire un
massacre donc c'est pas parce qu'une
opération est ratée qu' il n'y a pas
derrière un réseau par réseau qui a
manqué son objectif mais un réseau
néanmoins extrêmement dangereux et sans
doute assez ramifié l'attentât raté ou
encore une fois selon l'état islamique
de de villejuif va avoir des
conséquences sur la cellule des opex
abdel nasser ben youssef donc le le
concepteur le fondateur de cette cellule
a été vraisemblablement écarté
parce que
certains s'étaient plaints en interne
que ces apprentis terroristes n'étaient
pas assez fort mais qu on les formait à
la frontière ou pas assez longuement il
va être mis sur la touche
c'est ses deux amis et un peu
vraisemblement lieutenant qu'était
boubakeur el hakim et oussama atar qui
vont prendre sa place prendre du galon
et surtout mettre sur pied un projet
d'attentât beaucoup plus un ambitieux
qui sera malheureusement celui du du 13
novembre
il ya trois francophones qui ont été
arrêtés durant l'été 2015 et qui ont
parlé avec les services des services
français
[Musique]
en premier donc il ya de nicolas moreau
qui a été arrêté et expulsé arrêté en
nicolas moreau est un asiatique a grandi
dans l'ouest de la france et
qui a combattu en syrie il a fait partie
un peu des forces spéciales
vraisemblement l'état islamique
et cet homme quand il rentre au départ
se tait et un jour pendant sa garde à
vue va prendre la parole plus la lâcher
et il va confirmer des choses que l'on a
déjà et s'ils pressentaient il va leur
parler de l'amiante il va mettre un nom
sur ce service de renseignement
[Musique]
c'est le premier à parler je crois de
l'ania tu entends tu es l'un des
premiers à en parler expliqué qu'il ya
cette cellule des opérations extérieures
parlé du rôle d' à bas ou dhr et double
samatar commencé à parler de la route
des migrants et expliquer qu'ils ont des
dizaines
de volontaires pour le jihad prêt à
venir qui sont occidentaux est prêt à
venir mourir sur le sol français
[Musique]
le second chronologiquement ça doit être
tyler virus il tente de rejoindre
l'europe au mois de juillet 2015 et il
prend l'avion à istanbul avec leurs
passeports suédois en fait sa photo et
pas du tout ressemblante et la police de
l'air et des frontières turques tique un
peu et trouve un interlocuteur qui parle
suède world et forcément il sait pas
répondre et parle pas suédois
c'est un français que la déjà s y avait
dans son viseur il s'appelle tyler virus
il a fait partie de la police de l'état
islamique et par ailleurs c'est l'homme
qui a pris sous sa coupe un jeune belge
à son arrivée qui est abdelhamid abou
oud quand il vit hachadi là où
habitaient les combattants français et
belges il travaillait dans au sein de la
police islamique dans la même ville
vivait à mes dagano et stéphane et
samiya me bourdon et trois membres du
commando du bataclan
il est placé dans un centre de rétention
il arrive à se procurer ou à conserver
son son téléphone et il va échanger
avec about
il lui dit mais t'inquiète pas dès que
je sors je tape
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il devait participer un
attentat tout seul comme lui le prétend
ou et c'est la grande question est ce
qu'il devait être le onzième homme du
commando du 13 novembre et s'il l'avait
été
quel rôle il aurait joué car je le
rappelle c'est lui qui a formé about et
vu son parcours en syrie on le voit mal
avoir un rôle de simple exécutant si
j'ose dire
le troisième à être arrêté durant l'été
2015 et à parler de la menace des
attentats serré des rames
et il va le dire j'ai été clairement
mandaté par des amis de ben wood j'ai
été formé dans un centre spécial lié à
préparer et commettre des attentats en
europe une formation aux armes une
formation aux explosifs une formation
aussi à la communication cryptée
quand on l'a déjà issu lui demande
etes-vous courant d'une possible attaque
en france il explique que à l'heure
actuelle à jaca c'est une usine à
kamikazes il arrive
[Musique]
il nous dit voilà il y à une soixantaine
d'opérationnel qui sont sur quatre pays
mais c'est chercher une aiguille dans
une botte de foin parce que nous avons à
ce moment là plus ou moins
5000 combattants étrangers
d'origine européenne qui sont sur les
lieux
reda mais ils donnent une indication
supplémentaire cellules cibles
potentielles il dit que about lui a dit
de choisir une cible facile un concert
par exemple là où il ya du monde il m'a
précisé que le mieux après c'était
datant des forces d'intervention sur
place et de mourir en combattant avec
des otages soit exactement le programme
peut voir appliquer les trois
terroristes les trois tueurs au bataclan
on voit successivement à travers
différentes auditions de revenants de
que le rôle un peu plus précis daoud en
tout cas le rôle plus central dabao des
le risque ce que ça peut engendrer non
c'est pas où il est et c'est ça le pire
c'est que il a été logé en grèce en
janvier 2015 et après personne ne sait
où il est il est dans la nature on
commence à chercher plus ou moins dans
tous les sens et je dois avouer que
quand il se passe quelque chose sur le
thalys on n'est pas étonné
le thalys c'est une succession de
miracle si cet attentat et des jouets un
jihadiste al khazali monte dans le
thalys à bruxelles
[Musique]
va aux toilettes
pour sortir de son sac ses armes il a
une kalachnikov quand cazalis or il ya
quelqu'un qui voulait aller aux
toilettes chivu qui voit cet homme armé
qui essaye de le retenir ça l'a ralenti
là il y à ces militaires américains qui
ont compris que quelque chose n'allait
pas il a déjà tiré un premier coup de
feu autre coup de chance l'un
kalachnikov qui est réputé ne jamais
sont rayés s'enraye
[Musique]
ce sont des images d'elle khazani quand
il s'apprête à monter dans le thalys
vous le voyez jeune homme avec ses
petites lunettes de soleil sa valise le
fait est qu'on ne peut pas imaginer de
cet homme a dans ce sens dans cette
petite valise qu'on voit ici un arsenal
qui devrait lui permettre de tuer
plusieurs centaines de personnes s'y
sont en attente avaient réussi
été neutralisés par ces américains et et
par vaux 6 des français car il faut
aussi reconnaître que il ya eu des
voyageurs extrêmement courageux cet
individu aurait créé un carnage dans le
train saisi par les policiers un arsenal
de guerre fusil d'assaut kalachnikov et
pistolets automatiques
le terroriste présumé avait de quoi tuer
des dizaines de personnes on voit ce
risque d' attaque d'un train on voit ce
risque d' attaque d'un concert de rock
on sait que c'est dans les projets de
l'état et sami on commence à voir
quelques éléments mais on ne sait pas
quand ni où les choses vont intervenir
fin août on a tous ce passif et toute
cette menace qui est en train de monter
et il est clair que les services sont
très inquiets les ministres de
l'intérieur et président de la
république sont au courant quand on
interroge pareil patrick calvar le
patron de la dgsi dix la dangerosité
d'aba où dès l'été 2015 en indiquant que
cet individu était impliqué dans de
nombreux projets avortés c'était après
la taille du thalys nous savions
pertinemment qu'à baroud avait joué un
rôle dans plusieurs affaires dans la
sphère glam et nous l'avons donc signalé
oui les titans qui fait déjà depuis
plusieurs mois et presstalis mais on
peut dire après v revient aussi il est
déjà dans notre zone de 2,2 de
surveillance mais après on peut savoir
que cet individu joue un rôle important
dans le réseau après ou et l'individu en
question
[Musique]
paris va peut-être changer de stratégie
face au groupe etat islamique
la france devrait bientôt frapper les
djihadistes en syrie c'est ce qu'indique
nos confrères du journal la question a
été abordée hier lors d'un conseil
restreint de défense à l'elysée
l'entourage du chef de l'état ne
confirme rien
le 4 septembre 2015 à l'issue d'un
conseil de défense en présence du
président françois hollande la dgs va
faire un message interne dans lequel il
est écrit la neutralisation d'abdelhamid
about vecteur d'une menace avérée contre
notre territoire est devenu une priorité
urgente pour le service les services
renseignements nous communique des
informations qui sont parcellaires mais
qui toutes convergent pour indiquer la
dangerosité d'un individu et qui toutes
convergent pour pour dire que le long
procédé à sa neutralisation j'ai demandé
au ministre de la défense
que dès demain puissent être mener des
vols de reconnaissance au dessus de la
syrie ils permettront d'envisager des
frappes contre dash en préservant notre
autonomie de décision et d'action
[Musique]
la france a frappé en syrie cette nuit
la france à fabre et des ch en syrie
cette nuit à jaca nous avons frappé
parce que nous savons qu'il y a en syrie
en particulier dans les environs de jaca
des centres d'entraînement de
combattants étrangers dont la mission
n'est pas d'aller combattre pour des
chaussures le levant mais de venir en
france en europe pour commettre des
attentats c'est une action qui est
globale et nous ne réagissons pas
simplement parce que nous aurions des
terroristes identifié sur tel ou tel
lieu ça a pu arriver plus tard mais dans
la diction que je pense c'est une
décision stratégique
nous savons qu'il y à arak a notamment
des
immeubles qui servent justement à
accueillir un certain nombre de
personnes qui nous veulent directement
du mal et vous êtes sûr qu'il ya eu des
victimes djihadistes que vous avez tiré
puisque c'était la nuit qu'ils avaient
je ne commente jamais nulle part les
résultats des frappes que nous
effectuions mais je peux vous dire que
l'objectif a été atteint ces frappes de
l'automne 2015
sont cible des jihadistes supposé
préparer à des attentats visant la
france un jihadiste français le nom d'un
djihadiste français va être révélée par
le journal le monde mais en fait
il y avait un autre cible dont le nom a
été soigneusement tu sais tu es
abdelhamid about qui est elle la vraie
priorité des services
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas compris à cette époque que
abba ou devait quitter la syrie et pour
rejoindre à telle enseigne que le 3
novembre 2015 dont dix jours avant les
attentats la dgse a écrit que about se
déplacerait souvent entre deir ezzor est
la ville de mayadine donc on est quand
même très très loin d'abdelhamid about
qui alors à cette heure-là se trouvent
dans les environs de bruxelles
alors que les enquêteurs pensent que
abdelhamid à bas ou dom et en syrie
c'est une cible c'est un danger pour
l'europe et qu'ils essaient de mettre
leur toque de mettre leurs enseignements
le paquet en syrie à ce moment-là rang
abdelamid abou oud et remonter et il se
cache à bruxelles
[Musique]
about a décidé vu mes précédentes
attaques comment ça s'était passé il
décide de se présenter lui même et
devenir lui même préparé la prochaine
vague d' attaque il quitte la syrie
passe par la turquie il passe donc par
la route des migrants il arrive en grèce
et avec l'auteur du thalys il passe
passe certainement par un centre de
migrants ces papiers passe à travers il
ya pas de photo il ya des ratés à ce
moment-là
il remonte par la route des balkans on
sait qu'ils sont 1er août en hongrie
il est rentré en europe avec l cazalis
donc le futur terroristes du thalys et
qui l'avait envoyé
en éclaireur un jeune qui prenaient la
route des migrants et il échangé
ensemble en lisant à bastien cette route
là c'est sûr mathien la hongrie faut
faire ci ou faire ça et voilà il lui
ouvrait la voie
pour être à chaque fois dans des
conditions de sécurité maximum on a raté
about c'est clair même si house et pas
de grands chefs à beaune c'est celui qui
bouge c'est celui qui encadre et c'est
celui qu'on pouvait attraper donc les
dysfonctionnements il est fort possible
qu'il y en ait et le procès devrait être
le lieu où ces questions seront posées
[Musique]
about va se retrouver dans un
appartement avec casas me et sont jeunes
éclaireurs qui devrait seulement
participé à l'attentât du du thalys et à
partir de ce moment-là il y a un trou on
n'a pas su reconstituer l'itinéraire
daoud entre courant août et les derniers
jours qui précèdent le 13 novembre
à ce moment là c'est un grand désordre
en syrie c'est épouvantable l'ouverture
des routes pour les migrants va être
mise à profit par l'état islamique qui
se dit c'est ça notre solution on va
suivre les chemins des migrants et donc
on a plus de problème de papiers
finalement on n'a plus besoin de gens
qui ont des passeports en règle ou ont
des passeports européens on va pouvoir
voir des passeports syrien et on va
envoyer plusieurs dizaines de personnes
vers la france c'est la même scène qui
se répète inlassablement
des centaines de réfugiés éprouvé par
des semaines de voyage foulent le sol
européen pour la première fois
après villejuif
après les dames qui se fait arrêter
après verdier et après le thalys là il
ya volonté très claire de l'état
islamique de mon faire monter d'un
niveau les compétences des troupes on
envoie des guerriers chevronnés aguerris
qui ont tous un passé militaire au sein
d'états islamiques et puis comme on a
envoyé plein de gens on va pouvoir
organiser
à l'attentât avec beaucoup de monde est
une véritable
organisation en commando c'est de loin
la menace la plus structurée avec les
gens les plus aguerris
à laquelle on a eu à faire c'était des
hommes d'action qui était aussi soutenu
qu'ils étaient soutenus aussi par des
secteurs de la criminalité organisée je
parle au trafic d'armes je parle de faux
papiers je parle de ce genre de choses
pendant cet automne 2015 il ya des
individus qui a fait des faux passeports
parviennent à partir de la grèce à
entrer dans l'union européenne qui ont
un cheminement qu été reconstituée par
l' enquête qui ces jours notamment
belgique assez longtemps dans les
quartiers de molenbeek et il arrive pour
la commission de l'attentât de novembre
2015 qu'à la dernière minute
[Musique]
le 12 novembre il ya différents groupes
parmi les attaquants du 13 novembre qui
se forme et qui vont partir avec trois
voitures différentes pour paris
donc il ya un premier groupe était dans
une polo qu'on appelle le groupe des
français
il semble assez clair depuis le début
que c'est c'est eux qui vont attaquer le
bataclan ils le savent
ensuite une deuxième voiture quitte une
clio dans laquelle se trouvent les
frères abdeslam et leurs amis à brignais
donc ce sont les belges qui sont amis
qui se connaissent bien
il ya une dernière voiture qui est la
seat dans laquelle se trouve le
coordinateur donc abdelamid abou oud
chakib akrou et dans cette seat se
trouve également deux irakiens qui
seront les deux terroristes qui se
feront sauter au stade de france
[Musique]
ma fille ava venir elle va déjeuner je
me souviens encore quand je lui dis
vendredi 13 elle m'a fait comme ça et ce
geste
comme ça je dis à jean-françois mais
qu'est ce qu'elle m'a dit je me rappelle
pas à elle elle voulait dire je n'aime
pas
[Musique]
c'était une belle journée il est doux
c'était la fin de semaine on était
content d'aller au concert et on s'est
retrouvé dans la soirée
juste à côté du bataclan avec l'idée de
passer une bonne soirée ensemble
[Musique]